THAT.
I APPRECIATE.
WE'VE GOT A FOX NEWS ALERT.
MARTHA MCSALLY HAS CONCEDED THE
RACE IN ARIZONA.
THE NEW SENATOR WILL BE SINEMA.
A SURGE OF LATE COUNTED VOTES
CARRIED SINEMA TO THE LEAD.
LISA BOOTH HAS BEEN FOLLOWING
THIS RACE SINCE ITS EARLIEST
STAGES AND JOINS US TO EXPLAIN
WHAT HAPPENED.
WHAT EXACTLY -- IF YOU COULD
BOTTOM LINE WHAT HAPPENED IN
THIS ELECTION THAT MARCIA
MCSALLY AND EVERYONE ELSE
THOUGHT SHE WON, WHAT HAPPENED?
>> THE ASSOCIATED PRESS CALLED
THE RACE.
SHE HAS CONCEDED.
I THINK THE PROBLEM LARGELY
LOOKS LIKE MARICOPA COUNTY.
THE COUNTY REPRESENTS 60% OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION.
IT IS REPUBLICAN LEANING, BUT
SINEMA HAS BEEN LEADING.
THAT'S WHERE THE NEW VOTES CAME
IN TONIGHT THAT PUT HER OVER THE
TOP WHICH IS WHY THE ASSOCIATED
PRESS ENDED UP CALLING THE RACE.
I WOULD ALSO THINK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT PHA
FACT THAT MAA
FACT THAT MARTHA MCSALLY MIGHT
HAVE A CHANCE IN ARIZONA LOOKING
AT 2020.
SENATOR KYL IS REALLY A PLACE
HOLDER FOR THE LATE SENATOR JOHN
MCCAIN.
SHE POTENTIALLY EYED THAT RACE
IN 2020.
WHO EVER WINS THAT SPECIAL
ELECTION IN 2020 WOULD HAVE TO
RUN AGAIN IN 2022.
SO SHE MIGHT BE SOMEONE, YOU
KNOW, THAT WOULD THROW HER NAME
IN THE HAT FOR THAT RACE.
>> Tucker: FOR SURE.
I JUST READ AN ANALYSIS.
IT WAS ON 538 THAT SAID BETWEEN
2000 AND 2015, EVERY SINGLE
RECOUNT STATE WIDE THAT CHANGED
AN ELECTION RESULT CHANGED IT IN
THE DEMOCRATS FAVOR.
EVERY SINGLE ONE.
THAT DOESN'T PROVE ANYTHING.
YOU GOT TO ASK THE OBVIOUS
QUESTION.
THE OBVIOUS QUESTION IN THIS
CASE IS, MARTHA MCSALLY IS
SATISFIED THAT THIS PROCESS WAS
FAIR?
>> WELL, SHE CONCEDED.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHAT ARTICLES OR WHAT SURFACES
THIS WEEK.
IF THERE ARE ANY ARTICLES THAT
DRAW ANY ATTENTION TO ANYTHING
NEFARIOUS THAT WENT ON IN THESE
COUNTIES.
BUT RIGHT NOW SHE'S CONCEDED.
NOT ENOUGH FOR HER.
>> Tucker: CAN I ASK ONE MORE
QUICK DUMB QUESTION?
WE KEEP SEEING THE RACES WHERE
THEY GET CALLED.
ALL THE NEWS ORGANIZATIONS SAY
WE KNOW WHO THE WINNER IS.
THEN WE FIND OUT, WAIT, ALL
THESE VOTES THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
COUNTED.
WHY DON'T SECRETARIES OF STATE
ALERT THE PUBLIC AND THE
CANDIDATES AND US THAT WE'RE NOT
REALLY SURE BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
COUNTED ALL THE VOTES?
HAS THAT OCCURRED TO ANYBODY TO
DO THAT?
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
WE'VE ALSO GOT THAT GOING ON IN
GEORGIA NOW.
THAT RACE STILL HASN'T BEEN
CALLED.
WE SHOULD KNOW MORE INFORMATION
TOMORROW.
TOMORROW THE DEADLINE IS
TOMORROW FOR COUNTIES TO CERTIFY
RESULTS AND GET THOSE TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
HOWEVER, STACEY ABRAMS HAS TWO
LAWSUITS PENDING.
ONE TRYING TO MOVE THE DEADLINE